I just turned 30 you know I've never
been married I've had girlfriends and
whatnot and I've I've lived my
life but I I am someone
who doesn't need someone to motivate me
I think there are some men and I think
this is a big issue for these men they
need a woman in order to get their ass
off the couch the woman is what's
getting them to go and get things done
and if they break up with that girl
they're back to Couch Potato doing
nothing unmotivated and so yeah those
guys were nothing to begin with you know
they're basically what nags them and if
you have to be nagged to make something
out of yourself you're not a man in my
opinion you're a male but you're not a
man right this it's it's it's it's much
more common than not much more common
than not well a lot of you know males
today are adult boys you know it's all
they are they'll they'll you know they
think that it's enough to go get a job
and uh you know work 9 to5 and they make
their $47,000 a year and they they have
their uh Nissan Leaf they plug in every
night and
D they live very common basic lives you
know and their evenings are filled with
video games and uh you know weed and
porn and all that kind of like you know
they satiate themselves you know with
these U things to keep them distracted
and of course you know they follow
everything the mainstream media says you
know you want to jump how high you know
you want me to do this sure absolutely
how many times you want me to take that
you know there's all of these um softer
weaker males out today that aren't men
um and that's what good times create you
know good times do create softer men and
that's a consequence of the times that
we live in today I think that we're
going to see some harder times in the
coming years and things are going to
become more difficult and that'll
separate the wheat from the chaff and
that'll uh you know there's that whole
fourth turning right we're sort of like
moving into the fourth turning right now
where we're we're coming into the better
times but there's going to be a little
bit more difficulty still and I think
that these guys will be
tested for sure but I think that I'm
really glad I got this this this Clarity
and I I think I already understood this
but
yeah I because people will say and and
I'll be honest I'll I'll there
especially in my circles Orthodox Jews
some of the rabbis will say oh you know
don't worry about money as soon as you
find the girl you know God will bless
you with all this wealth and whatever
yeah that's and I'm I look at it and I'm
like it's crazy how many people blindly
just believe this guy I don't care long
your beard is I don't care how long just
Judaism it's not just Christianity like
they're all the same most religions
today are beta factories and they're not
they're not leading uh males into
adulthood into men like you guys in your
religion you have the right of passage
um what is it when they're
13 right what's it called the um permit
no but there's also a lot of see the
thing is original Judaism was not kind
of this feminist thing it that people
have reformed it because it's too
offensive but there's a lot Original
Scriptures that are not I had this
conversation with a couple of Christian
guys a few days ago I don't if you saw
the podcast that I did where they wanted
to talk about the Christian pill and
it's like you know they're of the
illusion that if she just loves God
enough and has a strong enough
relationship with Jesus everything will
be just fine and that's not how the
world works man like you know you can't
go and put 200,000 miles on a Ferrari
pull out all the dents clean up the
scratches change the carpeting roll back
the odometer back to zero put it in the
showroom and call it new it's not new
it's got problems you can you can call
it new but it's got problems and that's
I think one of the great failures of a
lot of modern religions today especially
in the west is like you me uh mentioned
is uh toxic feminism has uh polluted the
original messaging from the original
rule book which led men to be masculine
leaders and led women to be like
feminine uh compliments to their lives
right where men would have blue jobs
anden women would have pink jobs you
know sort of thing so I think if you're
going to sell any religion you you know
you really need to fix the club first
because there's there's infighting
there's disagreement uh you know there's
censorship of certain U terms in
scripture whether it's the Torah or the
Bible or whatever happens to be to
soften it down to be more inclusive to
not offend you know feminists or
anything like that um so you know it's a
real problem today it you know really is
my counter to rabbis making these
statements is no think if you're already
motivated this is my caveat if you're an
already motivated man where you on your
own accord have goals aspirations you
get up you go to the gym you work hard
you have your own business you're trying
to run you really have things that are
important to you with or without a woman
the right woman a woman who's a
compliment to you will help build it
she'll be people will see that you're
settled they'll see you know she's
attractive youve you found an attractive
woman inside and outside then I think
it'll be a compliment it'll show your
softer side right because if you're a
masculine guy she they'll see a
beautiful gentle Woman by your side
it'll that'll be a compliment to you
she'll help support you in your you know
say you're going through something you
don't necessarily have to be overly
vulnerable but she's your support system
she can help take care of certain things
you're out working she can make food
you're out that's what I talking about
yeah it's it's a whole unplugging
process it's it's absolutely a reality
um hope is a terrible plan and I think
that's what a lot of religion sell today
is just hope you know if you just
you know if you just be a nice guy and
you know you're a good person you show
up to church and you tithe or you know
whatever it happens to be uh your God
will send you a woman you know you are
entitled to it and you're not entitled
to and hope is a bad plan well in
Judaism there is a there is an idea of
you have to do your part we don't
believe that you can sit around and do
nothing there that's why I'm you know
I'm not the most religious person but if
you look at Judaism in its in at its
core without all the butter buttering
and and sugar coating they're very very
very good components that are very true
and I I truthfully think that I can't
speak for Christianity and Islam people
would look at Islam and say that as well
even though both of those religions
really get a lot of their principles
from Judaism Judaism at its core it's
pretty redpilled man you know it
definitely it definitely speaks about a
lot of
things in support of women but it
definitely has gender roles it
definitely talks talks about modesty
talks about all these things so yeah
that's why I think listening to all of
this content in the last couple of years
I think I already had a good idea of it
because of how I was
raised and then I obviously I learned it
through
experience but uh you know that's my two
cents I definitely don't think you have
to be a religious person to have these
understandings but at least certain
religious values I think could be
helpful yeah it's independent of any
religion you know for being honest I
really hope you guys enjoy that clip if
you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out